so even coasting tackle a show for just
over a year now he's almost 2 years
almost 2 years we started in 2000 I
start yeah technically I guess I started
January of 2011 but my contract started
November 2010 ok so so yeah I've been
there almost two years
I mean you now that you're you know a
regular feature on the tech they showed
you but do you still get nervous going
out every every day and family no piece
of cake no because I don't know I've
I've made so many mistakes on the show I
mess up all the time people are used to
it they know me they know that I say
weird things that don't make any sense a
lot of the time so I really feel like I
have nothing to fear now it has an
interesting though because we've had
since Kevin left we've had a whole
string of guest hosts and on Monday show
it's usually they're there for a week so
it's a new guest every week we've never
worked together before so it's
interesting finding that chemistry huh
or not I mean the chemistry you know but
like hoping that it's there so maybe I
do get a little bit of butterflies from
the Monday shows just because I don't
know exactly how it's gonna play out
Kevin I was listening to interview with
him and he's like I guess he'd been
doing stuff on the internet and stuff
with programming since he was like 10
years old or something's like this
really brilliant guy I mean was that
ever intimidating working next this guy
who had this just incredible catalog of
information about tech in the internet
culture or did he kind of help you and
kind of teach you a lot of the stuff
yeah he taught me a lot of stuff but
there's still a lot of stuff that he
wasn't into at all that we covered on
the show and I think people just kind of
expected him to be because he was more
tech savvy and it wasn't it didn't like
threaten me he's at Kevin's an amazing
host he's brilliant he's one of the
greatest hosts I've ever met and he's so
click on his feet and he's so smart but
I never felt intimidated by him I felt
like he was great to learn from what was
the kind of response did you see
culture people you know constantly
grilling you about if you know this
information if you're really into tech
all that kind of stuff oh yeah
all the time I mean all those questions
about comic books and games and tech and
anything you can imagine if if they're
into it and if I'm talking about it then
I have to know everything about it or if
I don't the people like well why don't
you know this I'm like I'm an actress
I'm a host this is my job I enjoy it I
love it but I'm not super hardcore you
know I I do this for a living so I don't
know
you guys got a lot of great guests on
attack of the show um it hasn't been a
someone a guest celebrity guest that
you've really you've really loved having
someone who's been like your favorite to
work with and someone who's been your
favorite to interview I had a really fun
interview with a monster' Hoffs key from
Chuck okay you know that she is
different and now she's now she's on
Dexter she came on and just had a great
a great time with her she showed me one
of her traditions where we had to eat
some white fish that was and and then
take a shot of vodka um totally random
but she was she was a sweetheart I had a
lot of fun with her Comic Cons always
crazy because we just have celebrity
after celebrity after celebrity Nathan
Fillion loved him he's such a sweetheart
very like just a great guy altogether
James Gunn who's a director he's come on
our show a whole bunch of times love him
I don't think I could pick a favorite I
mean there have been so many people but
yeah yeah Nathan Fillion that's really
cool yeah really great guy I need the
air guys I've watched him he seems like
an amazing person so he's just so fun
and down-to-earth that's that's what I
like to see people come on who are real
you know not all Hollywood and that are
just real people that are down to earth
that will shoot the [ __ ] with you and um
he's one of those guys absolutely you
know on tack of the show you guys have
the feed you have fresh ink you have
epic fail
together so many segments into the hosts
by so many great people do you have a
segment that you particularly love the
most on attack of the show I really like
around the net cuz we're finding videos
and
and it's it's tough it always makes me
laugh yeah most always makes me laugh
it's just like such a random weird stuff
but I love DV deuce day I like fresh ink
I like I like that our show has so many
different aspects to it I personally
like when I get to go travel somewhere
and do a segment and then it airs you
know later on in the week or in a month
or whatever because it it gives me the
opportunity to do so many different
things that I would have never done in
my life like I went to Utah State
University month or two ago and which I
had never been there I probably would
never go there I don't know great plays
but I tried on this like vacuum wall
feeling thing where I I climbed a
three-story building on the outside with
just this vacuum apparatus strapped to
my back when would I ever do something
like that
yeah that sounds crazy it was crazy and
it was hard as hell I had like 40 pounds
on my back that I had to like use just
my upper body strength weight so what
did the vacuum thing do well I was
harnessed in in case I fell right thank
God or had to give up and you know when
I got to the top I let go of everything
and then they pulled me down but it just
it's suctions it's kind of like a
spider-man thing or a Mission Impossible
thing but it would suction me to the
wall and then I would have to like pull
it off and then resection it and like
climb up the hallway that way like spies
use yeah it was crazy that's amazing
yeah it was fun do you have a favorite
you know viral video or youtube video
this year into right now or that an
all-time favorite or anything like that
an all-time favorite is probably the
great lady I mean I can watch that over
and over and over again
and not stop laughing I also like the
the dog where that guy's you know he's
like I have some bacon in the fridge
he's like ooh oh good the talking energy
what you do with it yeah I love that one
I don't know what it's called everyone's
like a talking cat ooh oh really it's so
amazing really great yeah that one's
really funny
I think you guys did Robert Kirkman and
he's kind of he's he's a comic writer
he's kind of reclusive man but he's
actually really great on camera he's
very I love Robert Kirkman I love The
Walking Dead
we've had him on a bunch he was also a
Comic Con I did The Walking Dead escape
where I like ran through the zombie
zombie obstacle course and he was there
and so we got to see him he's a great
guy you really like him he's very
charismatic and yeah I find that a lot
like it's just like a big teddy bear and
you're like how did you write this
horrible stuff you're so sweet this
nightmare book have you're watching the
the AMC show do you like this I'm
obsessed crazy yeah I can't wait for it
to come down it's coming back soon
really soon season three they're in the
prison and stuff so I'm so excited that
should be I can't believe the stuff they
get away with on AMC it's like so
violent you know like books and stuff
they're like awesome so what's like this
strangest fan reaction you've ever had
or like they're kind of the either like
a stranger really bizarre fan reaction
you've had I guess I don't know if it's
strange but um at e3 there was a guy who
was like hey Hannah's gonna get a
picture with you and I was like sure and
I'm taking a picture with him and he
sticks his hand on my butt and I'm like
I first I was like dude is he just like
swiping at it but he just sticks it on
there and I was like I'm sorry your
hands on my button he's like oh sorry
and he left it there and I was like what
are you doing get your hand off my butt
I'm still uncomfortable right now
yeah that was weird
that's a nightmare
you prefaced with that with I don't know
if that's strange that's that's strange
could we consider that strange
absolutely it's very strange
thank you so much for watching my
interview you can check out
interview at new media rockstars